you know they have these things where
girls ask their dads
name two of my best friends and dads can
never do it
taylor taylor let's stop there taylor
there you go got one
hey everyone i'm karen fox and i'm her
father jamie foxx
and this is the gq family quit
family affair
hey family oh hey family yes okay so
i'm going forward what's my rising moon
i'm going first
i'm going first i'm asking you questions
about me and then i'm gonna decide how
many points it's worth
oh i have a cure okay what's my favorite
meal
your favorite meal is gluten-free
okay gluten-free you're on track
gluten-free what
that's it no gluten-free what your
favorite meal is gluten-free
salmon i like salmon gluten-free
steak and potatoes it's pizza pizza
you know that though okay so i'm gonna
say half point because you got gluten
free and i'm proud that you even
acknowledged them for the fact that i
didn't acknowledge
a man from texas who lives by the steer
oh
okay i feel like you might know this
what is my favorite hobby
what's your favorite hobby yes mental
illness
no mental illnesses that's my that's my
cause well tell me about your cause i'm
an ambassador for nami the national
alliance for mental illness and it's a
big
passion of mine but you and my mom
almost got me this for my birthday
oh uh uh uh kayak there you go he likes
kayaking there you go you get one point
[Music]
what time was i born you were born
at 5 15. 7 17
a.m in the morning no no no we left at 5
15.
to go to the hospital yeah yeah but i
was born at 7 17 in the morning
and you know what matter of fact i got
it wrong oh that's central time
okay that makes sense so that's gonna be
zero points
i just know when you when you did come
out you did this
what's happening with it okay dad what
am i most scared of
what are you most scared of tight spaces
you get tired of water water
being underwater yes ding ding ding ding
ding
i did i did 47 meters down she did 47
meters
and i will never go underwater again you
don't like that on the water
that is one point i don't even like to
shoot what is only this much
i don't even know this what year did i
make my new york fashion week debut oh
that was 1946 no
no i'm not even close i think
it was 2010.
oh 2010 i was in 10th grade i think it
was 2017.
2016 2016. yes
wow they had to tell me that i'll give
you a point for that because i did not
know the answer
dad what is my favorite season think
about me
oh uh of valentine's day well yeah i
love boundaries because it's february
15th yes my birthday is the next day
yes i'll give that to you dad what was
the first time we walked
a red carpet together oh that was uh
2005
and it was the oscars yes she was 10
years old yes
they didn't know do you though no no
okay dad i know this you know this one
exactly
because it directly affected your life
exactly who was my childhood crush
come on dad it was three of them there
were three of them
you were just so out there at a young
age it was the jonas brothers
who did something to you what the
brothers do to you i don't know who the
jonas brother was
you thought they went to my did they go
to your school did they harm you back
then back in the day when i was
in love with them and i'm honestly
surprised they don't have a restraining
order against me because i saw these
dudes everywhere they went
in la for me it was joe
nick kevin but i love all of them
i still do i just went to their concert
oh no we're not asking about
my first boyfriend i know your first
boyfriend
yeah i know you do and i don't want to
ask i know i
named all my characters his name yeah
why
i don't know like subliminal tournament
who was my favorite singer growing up
uh uh um what's the group
singer he's singer singer we both we
both like her a lot
taylor swift oh yeah okay yep yeah i was
thinking rihanna but i also love doing
that yeah you love taylor swift i do you
know taylor
taylor sagittarius yes you guys have the
same birthday you do
i am a sagittarius half man half amazing
okay you definitely don't know this i'm
gonna ask you ask me what is my secret
hidden talent
oh your secret hidden talent is
predicting sunrises
is that anybody's secret that's her
hidden talent i've never really seen
anybody good
she would sit up as a little kid and she
go 5 58. i've never done that in my
life my secret talent is that i'm a
really good baton thriller
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute why didn't you become a baton
twirler
since i was a kid you've never seen it
though it's a hidden cow
yeah that's way hidden i ain't seen okay
some child is making up that
i'm nice i really am
right now all right bonus questions dad
okay let me just let me find a good one
for you
at all dad what is my dream travel
destination what is your dream travel
destination on vacation
i would say we went there a bunch every
summer for like three summers you took
me there
you took the boyfriend
paris you get a half point for that
bonjour
really what did i want to be when i was
a
kid
you wanted to be grown that's what all
kids want to do you want to grow up
i wanted to be in advertising that is
right and that's why you went to college
that's why i went to college okay nice
job dad
this is how many you got and i'm very
confident that i'm going to beat that
what is my great
grandmother's rising
that's not read off the card that read
you don't know your family see that's
what i'm talking about that's a
disrespect these children today
don't respect elders come on what is my
favorite tv show of all time
tough um
wow great am i right that's that's the
greatest tv show of all time
okay all right what is my biggest fear
you're not you're actually pretty yeah
pretty strong you're not really scared
of mud
pretty sure
yeah that's it exactly youtube oh how
many albums
have i released was there one that was
self-titled
yeah okay there's that there's
unpredictable
yes there's a story of a thousand
a thousand wrote yes there's blame it
isn't a single or that yeah it was a
single i'm gonna guess i'm gonna say
there's two in there that i don't know
i'm so there's five
you are correct yes fine
i knew it what is my most embarrassing
dad moment
i mean i feel like i can get this point
because it's really up to me right yeah
um most embarrassing dad moment i mean
toss up between
wearing too tight of clothes and
what are you saying harassing my high
school boyfriend
between those two that was all snoop
dogg's idea he's the one who harassed
the board and i'm having them to do it
he said hey look here help me come here
homie
hey what's pop okay what is my birthday
december 13th 1967. wow
vintage born in the struggle i was born
like this
out to the people how do you know when
i'm mad at you
you're in trouble huh i don't know
you don't get mad at me often i like to
stay on your good side
um how do you know when i'm mad in
general there's an energy
here's an energy shift i'll give you
that one i'll give you a half
appointment yeah
i don't know if i have this what is my
favorite hobby you like pickleball
oh my god perfect pickleball highest
rising sport
don't don't test me pickleball is like
standing on top
of a ping-pong table it's just short of
playing tennis it's a smaller court you
play
doubles it's addictive yeah he loves it
what sports did i play in high school
definitely football and basketball
wasn't good our best high school
basketball team was so bad you know how
they have banners
of when you won i would say welcome but
if but that if you had
to choose to be a professional athlete
would you be in basketball or football
i mean i would say football but my calf
muscles are a little too small
so i'll say basketball okay where did i
go to college
uh united states international goal
there you go and what was my major in
collage
classical piano well there you go i'm
cruising through
what is my favorite accessory
sunglasses yeah uh purvey revolt just
plug it in now i'm not trying to promote
anything like that because that would
just be
you know too much promotion or something
like that you know
revoke what was the first movie i was
ever in
toys wow toys i've never seen it
but i know you were in it this is the
type of respect
i was the guy what i was guy number one
just over the shoulder now i work for
that
it says guy number one just over the
shoulder of god bless
robin williams i was just over the
shoulder and i did a lot of this
did you have a line oh my gosh
you know i'm surprised i wasn't uh
recognized early on in my career
where was i born and where did i grow up
i don't know where you were
born you grew up in carroll texas but
were you born in california i'm gonna
have a point i was born in dallas i'm
gonna say you're we're in we're up in
terrell texas
what is the thing you remember when you
were riding in the turtle texas for the
first time
oh i mean i was really young there was a
sign what did it say there was a sign
as you walk in they said congratulations
you said dad
they spelled congratulations ross oh
yeah
yeah yeah it said congrad
what did i want to be as a kid white
you're right
i don't know a singer a piano player i
did i didn't want to be a singer and a
piano
i wanted to sing when you were younger i
did sing when i was young i i
did a great impersonation of lionel
richie heaven jerry curl and the whole
nine is amazing
i started playing piano when i was five
years old my grandmother started me out
on classical piano the reason that i
liked it was my older adopted brother
played and i just thought he was the
coolest and so you know i wanted to be
like him
all right what was the favorite movie i
was ever in what was your favorite
what was my favorite movie that i was
ever in
i feel like it's going to be between
django and ray right
i feel like you really enjoyed django
because you got to be on the horn
you know in that order what year did i
win the oscar for roy
roy ray i'm sorry
yeah there's a different movie i did roy
was sort of like this sex
uh sort of like soft uh
well you know what i had one major line
roy
don't you do this to me roy bro where
you been roy
roy is you kidding or are you kidding
roy
and then
[Music]
yes wow i can't believe i missed that i
wanted to answer your question
2005. one for rey yes
i'm sorry i miss roy that's so good you
know
i'm gonna release that on betamax listen
we had a great time and karen this is
how many you got right i clipped you
and no i definitely definitely
won as i knew i would well that was it
guys thanks for watching we appreciate
it
and i definitely crushed